[Music]
in america
one is free to profess any view any
belief
one is a free citizen however let the
american try not to go to church or let
him try to praise communism
and something will happen whereby he
will stop working
in the big little town he himself will
not even notice how it happened
the people who will get rid of him
themselves do not believe in god
but they go to church as for communism
well that is something for mexicans and
slavs
it is no business for americans
imagine this you take an immense
mountain chain cut it at the root
turn it upside down and push it onto
even land
covered with forests then you take it
out
what remains is the mold of a mountain
chain its mountains
are upside down that is the grand
canyon
mountains must be looked at from below
the canyon
from the top down the spectacle of the
grand canyon does not have its equal
anywhere on earth
of course we should have gone down to
the bottom of the canyon and lived there
for half a year in a log cabin with
steam heating but we only did what we
could
drove around the canyon in an automobile
out of the grand canyon there was a new
road untraveled yet by tourists
the tall thick forests of the national
park became gradually thinner
and finally disappeared altogether it
suddenly turned dark and cold
we ran out of petrol we were hungry when
immediately
from around the bridge a light gleamed
and we drove up to a house
near the little house we noticed with a
sigh of relief a petrol station
the house represented what in russian
and in spanish is called
a rancho but in english a ranch
so here in the desert where for 200
miles around there is not a single
settled habitation we found excellent
beds
electric lights steam heat hot and cold
water
we found all the conveniences of any
house
in new york this little house contains
all of american life
complete comfort in a desert side by
side with the purple wigwams of the
indians
no matter where you go as a traveler to
the north to the south or the west or to
new york new orleans or new jersey
you will see everywhere poverty
and riches stand hand in hand at all the
roads
and at all the bridges of this great
[Music]
country
this video is sponsored by magellan tv
the documentary streaming service
wake up day from coco she's been very
busy recently working on her new
documentary for magellan
a fascinating exploration of the birds
that fly around outside our window
and go into the bathroom just outside
the litter box
yeah i know that was you but to tide you
over before coco finishes her
masterpiece
her recommendation this week is the last
sarinas
which delves into the world that
disappeared to make way for our soviet
tourists
ilf and petrov as always magellan offers
great context
to our content it's a sort of netflix
for documentaries with a huge range of
great history stuff among
loads of other genres much of which is
available in 4k
click on the link in the description for
an exclusive month-long free trial for
voices of the past viewers
thanks
here began the reservation of a nomad
indian tribe
the navajo this is one of the largest
indian tribes
it consists of 60 000 people
the navajos loathe and test their
white-faced brothers who have been
exterminating them for two centuries
driving them into worse and worse places
and finally
into a fruitless desert the government
which formerly devoted itself to
destroying the indians
is now trying to preserve their small
number of descendants
so-called indian reservations have been
built where the whites are permitted to
trade with the indians
under state control having chased the
indians away from the fertile ground
they have reserved for them only a few
pathetic parcels of desert
and this is regarded as a great act of
benevolence
their opened museums of indian art they
buy from the indians for a pittance
their drawings rug painted clay bowls
and silver bracelets
americans are rather proud of the
indians
even so does the director of a zoo take
pride in a rare old lion
on the border of california we were
stopped at the inspector's station
it is forbidden to transport fruit or
flowers into california
the inspector pasted on our windshield a
label portraying unnaturally blue vistas
and green palms
and we found ourselves in california
in the golden state california
cried mr adams suddenly is a remarkable
state
as a matter of principle there is never
any rain here
you will simply insult a californian if
you tell him that rain is possible here
if on the day of your arrival it rains
anyway the californian will be very
angry
will shrug his shoulders and say this is
something incomprehensible
i have been living here for 20 years one
of my wives died here and another
fell ill here my children grew up and
graduated from high school
this is the first time i have seen rain
he laughed americans laugh and never
stop showing their teeth
not because something humorous has
happened to them but because laughter is
their style
america is a land that loves
explicitness in all its affairs and
ideas
it is better to be rich than to be poor
so instead of wasting time on thinking
of the causes of poverty and eliminating
them
the american tries in every possible way
to acquire
a million dollars it is better to laugh
than to weep
so he laughs no doubt in the past he has
forced himself to laugh
just as he forced himself to sleep with
the windows open to indulge in
gymnastics and to brush his teeth
subsequently these things become daily
habits and now
laughter rattles in his throat
irrespective of his circumstances or his
wishes
if you see a laughing american it does
not mean that something strikes him as
comical
he laughs only because an american
must laugh
[Music]
we were rolling over the streets of san
francisco
this is the most beautiful city in
america
apparently because it is in no way
reminiscent of america
most of its streets rise from hill to
hill an automobile journey through san
francisco looks more like a sideshow
called
american mountains and presents the
passenger with a number of
strong sensations nevertheless in the
center of the city is a piece which
looks like the flattest
leningrad in the world with its squares
and broad avenues
the other parts of san francisco form a
remarkable seashore mixture of
naples and shanghai here as everywhere
else in america
was limitless wealth and limitless
poverty standing side by side
shoulder to shoulder but wealth here did
not seem as depressingly monotonous and
dull
while poverty was at least picturesque
[Music]
we drove towards the golden gate here
ends lincoln highway the auto strata
between new york and san francisco
american technicians are people of
amazing modesty
the end of their concrete masterpiece
which unites the atlantic
and the pacific oceans they have marked
with a memorial column
only three feet high on which are the
letter l
a small bronze base relief of lincoln
and the inscription
the western end of the lincoln highway
the names of the builders of the road
remain unknown and what of it
the people who a year from now will be
driving across the bridges of san
francisco bay
will not know who planned and built them
thanks to the kindness of the bridge
builders we were granted permission to
look at their work
the san francisco oakland bridge eight
and a half miles long consists of
several bridge spans of different
types now they were finishing the
spinning of the steel cable on which the
bridge will hang
its thickness is almost a meter in
diameter that cable
hanging over the bay is safely provided
with a wire net for the workman to walk
on
we ventured to make a short journey
along the cable
we felt as if we were on the roof of a
skyscraper with only this difference
that there was nothing at all under our
feet except a thin
wire through which the waves of the bay
were visible
strong wind was blowing although the
journey was quite safe
we clutched the cable with desperation
how thick it is said mrs adams our
travelling partner
trying not to look down a beautiful
cable confirmed mr adams her husband
without letting the upper steel support
out of his hands
and now let us go higher the guide
proposed to the very top of the pylon
what a cable mr adams exclaimed i simply
don't want to go away from it
but we don't have to go away from it we
will go up alongside the cable the guide
said
no no in this particular place the cable
is especially good
mr adams looked down by chance and
instantly shut his eyes
an excellent excellent cable he muttered
write that down in your little books
just as long ago thousands of cities a
score of deserts and
a score of states ago we had been almost
sucked in
by new york our notebooks were filled
with a multitude of notes
signifying the dates of business
appointments of business luncheons and
business cocktail parties we were
leading the life of business-like
americans
without having any business at all
our free day was finished by a visit to
a football match
the teams of two universities were
playing santa clara
and texas christian but before passing
to a description of this event which
to some extent helped us to understand
the nature of america
it is necessary to say a few words about
american football
in general football in america means
this
the very largest stadium the very
largest congregation of people and
automobiles in one place the very
loudest noise that can be emitted
through the oral cavity of a certain
creature with two hands two legs one
head and one hat put on a slant
it means the very largest appropriation
of money a special football press and a
special football literature stories
novelettes and novels of football life
a big football match in america is an
event of much greater significance than
a concert by a symphony orchestra
a cyclone in florida a war in europe or
even the kidnapping of a famous
millionaire's daughter
the grandstands of the stadium filled in
the center were almost vacant on the
ends
still there were approximately 30 000
people there
at first the play seemed
incomprehensible and
therefore not interesting american
football has
nothing in common with european football
these games resemble each other
so little that when in new york in a
newsreel theater a portion of a football
match between two european teams was
shown
there was laughter in the audience and
so
for some time we could not understand
what was going on
on the field
people in leather helmets looking a bit
like sea divers
some of them in red others in white
stood facing each other
their heads and backs bent and for
several seconds
kept standing without moving then a
whistle blew
and these people dashed frantically away
from their places
the reds and the whites got mixed up as
it seemed to us seizing each other by
their legs
such a commotion occurs in a chicken
coop when a pole cat appears
then they all fell on top of each other
forming a large pile of bodies
in motion the first few minutes we did
not even see the ball that is we noticed
it but only for a second or two
and then again we lost sight of it
gradually we learned to follow the ball
and to
estimate the situation by the end of the
first quarter
we began to understand a little about
american football
and by the end of the second quarter we
were already great experts repeated the
names of the best players
and yelled with all the other onlookers
[Music]
it is terrible to say it right out but
hollywood
whose fame has gone around the world
hundreds of times
hollywood about which in the last 20
years more books have been written than
in 200 years about shakespeare
the great hollywood on whose firmament
stars rise and fall
a million times faster than astronomers
have told us about
of whom dream hundreds of thousands of
girls in all ends of the terrestrial
globe
this hollywood is dull
hellishly dull and if a yawn continues
several seconds in any small american
town
here it stretches into a full minute and
there are times when one simply cannot
muster enough strength to close his
mouth
there you sit your eyes squinting with
boredom
your mouth wide open like a trapped lion
hollywood is a correctly planned
excellently paved and finely lighted
city in which live
three hundred thousand people all these
three hundred thousand either work in
the motion picture industry
or serve those who work in it
we moscow theater patrons are somewhat
spoiled by american cinematography
that which reaches moscow and is shown
to a small number of cinema specialists
at nightly previews
is almost always the best that hollywood
creates
moscow has seen the pictures of lewis
milestone king vidor reuben macmullian
and john ford cinematographic moscow has
seen the best pictures
of the best directors these directors
with the exception of chaplin
who releases one picture in several
years make 5
8 10 pictures a year but
as we already know americans shoot 800
pictures a year
all the more depressing therefore was
the impression american cinematography
left with us
after we became acquainted with it in
its own
native land
in new york we went to the motion
picture theaters almost every evening
usually two feature pictures are shown
during one performance
thus we must have seen more than 100
feature pictures
alone all these pictures are below the
level
of human dignity it seems to us that it
is degrading for a human being to look
at such pictures
they're designed for birds brains for
slow thinking human cattle of camel-like
lack of fastidiousness every evening we
would enter a motion picture theater
with a vestige of hope
and departed with the feeling of having
eaten in all its detail the famous lunch
number two
of which we were duly sick and tired
however
the spectators the most ordinary
american garage mechanics
sales girls store keepers liked these
pictures
at first we wondered about it later we
were
worried about it and then we began to
understand
how it all came about there are four
main standard types of pictures musical
comedy
historical drama a film of bandit life
and a film featuring some famous opera
singer each of these standard types has
only one plot
which is varied endlessly and tiringly
american spectators see one in the same
thing year in
and year out they've become so
accustomed to it
that if they were presented with a
picture that had a new plot they would
undoubtedly burst into tears
like the child from whom his favorite
toy had been taken
though it was old than broken
for several days we taught the studios
on the territory of the studio an entire
city is built
it is the strangest city in the world
from a typical street
in a small american town with a garage
and a 5 and 10 cent store
we walked out onto a venetian square
right behind the palace of the doge
could be seen a russian inn all the
decorations are made to look like the
original
several steps away you cannot believe
that these monumental entrances into
cathedrals these
coal mines ocean ports bankers offices
paraguayan villages
are made out of beaver board coloured
paper
and plaster of paris
we walked out of the studio and half an
hour later was slowly rolling along
with the automobile flood which was
making its way to santa monica
to breathe the ocean air the great
motion picture capital
smelled of petrol and fried ham
young girls in bright flannel trousers
were busily walking the sidewalks
all the girls of the world congregate in
hollywood
here the very freshest merchandise is
needed
crowds of those who had not yet become
rising stars
beautiful girls with unpleasant spiteful
eyes
fill the city here we saw a man whose
profession is
in all probability inimitable this man
sat under a large striped umbrella
beside him was placed the following
billboard
houses of motion picture stars from 9 am
until 5 30pm although the business day
was at its height
no one engaged the guide and on his face
was expressed in
irrepressible disgust for his foolish
profession
and for american motion pictures
further on we saw a young man standing
in the middle of the pavement
on his chest hung a placard which read
i am hungry give me work
no one walked up to this man either
the vastness of the ocean the steady
wind that blew towards the shore
the tranquil pounding of the surf
reminded us
that in this world there is still life
that is real
with real emotions which do not
necessarily fall within a set quantity
of footage
filled with tap dancing kisses
and gunshots
you